[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meine torten wird
heute ist teil fünf jahre und ich werde
heute wieder etwas süßes vorbereiten
erst am abend habe ich euch gefragt was
er denn gerne sehen würdet und ihr habt
euch für die apple karamell cookies
entschieden also für die apfel karamell
kekse die cookies die so richtig schön
groß also wie die amerikanischen cookies
eben auch und ich hab hier für meinen
parlament selbst gemacht wird es aber zu
umständlich ist kann natürlich auch
fertigen karamell kaufen ihr könnt diese
karamellbonbons nehmen oder was ich
jetzt ganz neu entdeckt habe finde ich
natürlich ganz super das sind jene
karamell glöckchen die gibt es einfach
anfangen was sie kaufen
das sind so ganz kleine würfel und die
sind natürlich da fragte schon handlich
und man kann es natürlich richtig gut
dosieren
ich zeige euch jetzt aber trotzdem
einmal wie man den karamell herstellt
und was ihr dazu an zutaten benötigt für
die karamellbonbons braucht ihr 100
gramm schlagsahne 100 gramm zucker und
wer noch da hat etwas parlament sitzt er
vom grafschafter den braucht ihr nicht
unbedingt aber ich denke es gibt so ein
richtig schönes karamell aroma mit in
die bonbons und jetzt gibt dir einfach
die zutaten in einer pfanne
ein spritzer karamell sirup gehabt so
ein bisschen das ganze wird jetzt
verrührt und bei höchster stufe erst mal
aufgekocht und lasse es einfach weiter
kochen gehört auch und so etwas durch
bis die masse richtig schön karamell
fahren ist
[Musik]
und wenn es dann diese farbe angenommen
hat ich weise doppeltes gut sehen können
durch die kamera dann rechts hat auch
ziemlich nach karamell
dann nehmt das auf jeden fall vorher
drunter passt doch auch weil durch die
pfannen hitze wird es ja noch weiter
brown aber so die farbe ist wirklich
perfekt
und dann geht da diese masse einfach auf
dem backpapier und verstreicht hier das
einfach so ein bisschen schon ziemlich
zähflüssige masse wenn der körper meldet
dann fertig ist muss einfach noch
abkühlen in der zeit könnt ihr schon mal
den teig herstellen und den teig den ich
euch heute zeige das ist ein grund teig
das heißt aus diesem tal könnt ihr alle
cookies herstellen ihr könnt wenn ihr
schokoladen cookies machen wollt einfach
einen teil des mädels durch kaka
ersetzen und da wirklich jede
geschmacksrichtung man heute wie gesagt
manchmal apple parlament cookies und
zeigt ob ich deswegen jetzt leicht die
zutaten für den teig braucht ihr 125 g
weiche butter 125 gramm zucker eine
packung oder einen esslöffel vanille
zucker einen teelöffel backpulver und
eine prise salz
ihr braucht 1 1 200 gramm mehl
das waren jetzt so die grundzutaten und
da ich heute apfel karamell cookies
machen werde die karriere habe ich jetzt
schon brauche ich jetzt hier noch einen
apfel und wer möchte kann das ganze mit
sind und mit etwas muskatnuss verfeinern
zuerst kommt jetzt die butter in eurer
rührschüssel die ist sehr weich
die werde ich jetzt auf stufe vier bis
sechs früher
und wer dann nach und nach dem zucker
dazugeben
[Musik]
die mutter wurde jetzt auch auf höchster
stufe verrührt jetzt gebe ich da noch
dass ein mieter so und verrührt es auch
in höchster stufe
und jetzt kommt ja noch das mehl mit
zucker und backpulver vanille zucker und
salz
und das wird jetzt einmal ganz kurz
eingebunden und wer möchte kann jetzt
hier ein paar gewürze mit dazugeben ich
gehe jetzt grad sonne so einen halben
teelöffel zimt mit rein und etwas
frischer muskatnuss mira schlägt mir den
ganzen tag weg den teig las ich ganz
kurz stehen und kümmere mich kurz um den
absolut um die karamellbonbons den apfel
möchte ich jetzt angst box scheele
dann werde ich hier das kerngehäuse
entfernen und ihn dann in kleine würfel
schneiden
so sehen jetzt die apfel würfel aus mit
zeige ich euch nicht die karamellbonbons
und zwar wird man sieht auch schneiden
aber ich möchte jetzt einfach ein
kleines stück brechen
ihr müsst mal ausprobieren also vom
geschmack her so sieht es dann aus
wundert euch jetzt nicht über die menge
an so dass gerade die doppelte menge ich
habe es nämlich heute schon zwei mal und
jetzt nehmt euch einfach die äpfel und
die karamellbonbons und hebt sie unter
den teig ich ziemlich fest falls ihr
euer in größe älter hat weiß ganz gut
wenn das nicht
lassen sich fest mir und sie sind
einfach ein grüner und dann zieht das
ganze etwas so aus eine ziemlich grobe
teigmasse dann habt ihr zählen backblech
vorbereitet mit etwas backpapier oder
back folie besser gesagt wenn ich bin
halt was so ein eislöffel dann kann man
nämlich damit ganz gut funktioniert und
gebt ihr jeweils eine kugel dorfs
backpapier die cookies gehen jetzt beim
backen noch auseinander deswegen macht
last genug platz zwischen den ohren und
jetzt drücke ich sie einfach mit lassen
konnten ein bisschen flach und so gebe
es jetzt bei 175 grad für etwa zehn
minuten in den backofen
so sehen sie jetzt nach dem backen aus
dies sind jetzt noch ganz brüchig da
müsste jetzt wirklich vorsichtig sein
das da am besten so ein paar minuten
liegen
danach werde ich sehr auf einen auskühlt
gitter geben damit sie vollständig
abkühlen können und die cookies sind
noch ziemlich hell wie ihr seht
allerdings ist daran tier schon leicht
braun ich habe dir jetzt auch zwölf
minuten im ofen dann müsste einfach mal
schauen wie offen so backt aber es ist
auf jeden fall fertig das sieht man
einfach trauen dass die oberfläche fest
ist daran gleich frauen unten sind sie
bestimmt auch schon so parlament farben
braun und länger dürfen sie auch nicht
packen weil es sonst zu trocken werden
und ihre cookies eigenschaften verlieren
ich habs jetzt heute so gemacht dass
sich die apfelstückchen in würfel
geschnitten habt das nächste mal wird
ich allerdings die äpfel er reiben oder
in social and stifte schneiden meint
sich dann einfach da teig viel leichter
faszinieren lässt wenn da nicht diese
großen apfelstücke mit drin sind
außerdem finde ich dass sich dann die
äpfel besser im teig verteilen aber den
geschmack habe ich jetzt keinen abbruch
getan also die art von karamell gut
schmecken trotzdem wunderbar und das ist
einfach nur so ein vorschlag den er
eventuell
anders machen können weil ich dann auch
den apfel eben auf den ganzen tag
verteilen könnt und ihr ebenso mehr
davon habt mit dem karamell bist du
jetzt vorsichtig sein mit interessieren
ihr habt ja im teig schon genug zucker
das heißt weil es nicht ganz so süß mag
kann etwas weniger karamell verwenden
oder eben nur ein kleines
karamellbonbons betreiben geben
ansonsten würde ich euch empfehlen
vielleicht etwas zucker zu reduzieren ja
also mir persönlich waren die cookies
etwas zu süß mein mann mag sie aber so
also ich würde für mich persönlich das
nächste mal eben teig etwas weniger
zucker nehmen oder einfach weniger
karamell cookies damit das ganze nicht
so ab süß wird
ich werde mich jetzt ganz da noch die
fertigen cookies seiten allerdings sind
sie leider schon aufgegessen und ich hab
zwei größen vorher nummer zu filmen und
aber ihr habt ihr gesehen wie sie
aussehen und wenn die cookies ausgekühlt
sind sind so richtig schön weich sowie
im koki sein sollen
ich hoffe dieses konzept gefällt euch
und ihr werdet mal ausprobieren wie
gesagt könnt ihr dieses rezept einfach
umwandeln und andere cookies draus
machen oder eben mal diese version
testen fand ich es richtig lecker ich
wünsche euch auf jeden fall viel spaß
beim nachbacken wünsche euch noch einen
ganz schönen tag morgen kommt dann mein
voraussichtlich letzter teil für das
skript für das herbst special
ich werde dann nämlich meine kürbissuppe
noch vorstellen
und ja dann möchte ich schon mal viel
spaß dabei und bis morgen
[Musik]